okay now i'm curious about the reason
for secrecy behind this whole uap
phenomenon and i'm curious do you
believe that it's profit driven
primarily or that it's so profit driven
by the private sector or profit driven
by the governmental sector or that it's
altruistically motivated like tom delong
may espouse or tom delong believes
are we talking what can we can you
identify what exactly are we asking
about what is the
there's much that is covered up about
the reason for secrecy you're asking
about what what is you're asking my
opinion on
the reason behind it
it's my opinion just by looking at the
simple record that we that we can that
we can distill that that made front page
news that did get reported that wasn't
completely redacted
i think we see um a great a great deal
of shock and confusion
and if we're to assume
that some of what we all assume about
crashes and bodies and things like that
if that occurred
we're still debating what that would do
to our religions our society our culture
our stock market all of those things we
still debate that to today with the with
the pretty split
constituency of who believes that we're
ready and who believes that we're not
and i think we can see a natural
progression of not understanding
something
wanting to understand it before they
made it public
but then human nature probably i can
imagine took over
and so power mongering
um greed
uh idea mongering you know thought if
that makes sense um wanting to keep you
know important ideas to yourself i can
see that that would have happened
already but i still think that
the government that i the military that
i worked in and the government that i
operated in and around was made of just
regular folks like us
and
it this is an incredibly daunting
subject
and so i can see where
it would have continually been kicked
down the road now that's just my opinion
just from from
looking at what's in in the public
record
um
what do you mean by that it would have
been continually kicked down the road
no i've never met anyone who wants to
take responsibility for this
and it's one of the things that made lou
very interesting a few years ago when he
appeared was that he was he had the
courage to do it and he wasn't doing it
in the same way everybody else did it
and he wasn't asking for your money
and he you know he wasn't on the same
nonsensical you know the tv shows i
shouldn't say the nonsensical television
shows the things that are where you
sandwich important information in
between fiction
um it always leaves a plausibility
deniability and and lou doesn't mess
with that stuff it's like look here's my
record and now we can see the people
that tried to try to silence him
and so it was very very different
um
where are all the other lose
we know they existed where are all the
other program managers we're the foreign
program managers
um they're not speaking up there's a lot
of
simple questions as to why whether
they've been threatened whether they're
under under nda
but i talk to a lot of people every day
who want to help in this subject very
high profile people
but but they don't want their names out
there yet attached to it they believe in
it they think it's real
but they're still waiting for that
tipping point to where we stop laughing
at it where it stops ruining careers and
ruining brands or we're changing
people's minds about you as an
individual
um that's primarily stigma that's
keeping them from speaking out
non-anonymous
i would say that i would say that
primarily stigma and and um
and wanting to
let me try to make an analogy here that
if if i brought a um
if i came back to the
to the tribe around the campfire
and i brought a uh a power saw
what are we going to use it for
it has a purpose it's for cutting wood
but a lot of the folks in the tribe are
probably going to want to use it to go
take over the other tribe next door
because it's the most powerful weapon
they've ever seen
and right there we may just be talking
about human nature
but i think that there's so much of our
humanity wrapped up in the answers that
we all assume are part of this
that very few people have been willing
to take responsibility in any way shape
or form
lou
what do you believe to be the primary
reason
look kurt i'm um for lack of
transparency yeah i'm a little more more
practical and and probably a little bit
more um
less optimistic um
for our species of this particular
question
what if there was
knowledge
kurt that
was
so volatile
so earth-shattering
that the mere knowledge of that getting
out
could predicate
an action that could potentially
threaten the entire species now what do
i mean by that
for just a moment
take off the scientific hat
take off your humanitarian hat take off
your
your philanthropic hat and put on a hat
of national security
um
you just we just talked about the fact
that there's no indication that these
things have been here to help us okay um
there
that so there's really only three
possibilities they're benign uh or or if
you will benevolent
or two uh they are malevolent they're
here to hurt us or three they're just
here to observe us and they're capable
of doing both good and bad like us well
if you were to put on your national
security hat for a second let's say
you're a general from the 1950s or 60s
and your job is to protect america and
all things good and great and uh the
height of the cold war and you've got
the you know the soviet bear across
there and
things are pretty tough right um and
nuclear proliferation is a real thing
now um
you have information that there is
something here that is can outperform
anything you have
and really anything you have is is is
rather ineffective from a national
security perspective and there's a thing
out there
and it doesn't show that it's being
benevolent so it's only one of two other
options either malevolent or it's like
us
and we see this very careful
isr uh surveillance of our nuclear
equities it's interested in nuclear
equities well some may look at that as
what we call preparation of the
battlefield okay and and let's just say
hypothetically there's a 10 percent
chance u.s has a 10 chance that these
things are bad or or one day they're
going to come here in force and they're
just they're they're looking at us right
remember you're putting on your national
security hat so forget about everything
else for a moment your job is to be
paranoid
and there's a small remote chance that
these things
are not good
um and maybe there is a plan for these
things at some point to come in force in
50 years from now
and if the mere fact you have this
conversation uh with the american people
what's going to happen well the american
people can start getting prepared
well you know i can tell you in real
life combat situations when we send in
long-range surveillance nurse teams you
know behind enemy lines the moment the
enemy finds out that we know um
that that that they know we're there um
the surprise element of surprise is over
and so ultimately hypothetically imagine
a scenario where maybe we had 50 years
to prepare for something but now that
the cat's out of the bag
um
that existential action will happen
tomorrow and by the way we're not ready
for it we're not prepared for it we
don't have a counter measure we don't
have a capability to counter this and so
from a very real perspective a national
security perspective the mere fact that
you are acknowledging the existence of
something may predicate an action or an
act that you're not prepared to have
right now
um and so i i encourage you and your
listeners to just for a moment i'm not
asking you to be a national security
person but i'm asking you to suspend
your personal beliefs right now for just
a moment and put yourself in somebody
else's shoes who does feel that way
right now what do you do
if the mere fact of talking about this
could potentially cause a reaction that
you're not ready for as a country as a
civilization
right maybe that's the reason why you
decided to only brief certain presidents
who have a background in intelligence
maybe they were former directors of cia
but the other presidents who are career
politicians will be you know they're
here today gone in four years maybe you
can't even risk telling them
and so maybe the reason why this has
been kept secret so long is actually in
a weird sense some sort of sense of
patriotism by people
and and you know maybe maybe that's how
they justify it um
and i'll leave that at that as a as a
you know just a
as a counterpoint of forcing people to
think maybe a little bit
non-traditionally now do i think if that
happened to ever be the case that's
that's
that's that's a good explanation no
i i still think that we have to be
honest with the american people you know
it's like going to i said this before
it's like going to the doctor
just because i have cancer you know it's
bad news don't don't keep that from me i
want to know because maybe there's a
chance i can do something about it right
so but but do i understand that
mentality sure nobody wants to give
anybody bad news now am i saying that's
the case no i'm not it's just you ask me
one of the reasons why people would want
to keep this secret well that's a really
damn good reason why people may want to
keep this secret because the mere fact
of not keeping it secret could cause a
reaction that you're not ready for yet
there's nothing you can do you don't
have a counter measure so again from a
national security perspective you know
that that makes sense again i don't
agree with it but you know that
that's understandable